Kirupa Chinnathambi:
Alright.
Welcome, everyone.
Welcome. Great to see you all
in person, as well as to those
of you watching online.
So, here's the thing.
Agents today, they're no
longer confined to a checkbox.
They're not waiting for you
and I to tell them what to do.
They're taking action.
They're calling tools.
They're running
workflows end-to-end
that are pretty complex
that would have been almost
unimaginable just a few
months ago.
So, the problem is this.
It's not about
capabilities anymore.
Agents are plenty capable
and we're a lot more productive
as a result of that.
No, what we want
is we want agents
to run safely and predictably.
And in this session,
we're going to learn all
about the capabilities
Windows is providing
to help your agents
do just that.
My name is Kirupa.
I'm a Product Manager
in the Windows Platform
and Developer team.
I'm joined by Stuart,
an architect also
on the Windows Platform and
Developer team, and Patrick,
a Project Manager at GitHub.
You'll be hearing
plenty from Stuart
and Patrick throughout
this session.
Now, before we go into
the technical details,
I want to take a step back.
As you can see from
these headlines,
the way agents are being
used today; it's not great.
As agents are gaining more
capabilities and work
with greater autonomy, they're
causing real problems.
Either in the wild,
or maybe even
within our own organizations.
And if I had to
generalize, the reason is
that we're moving very
quickly from AI that responds
and answers to AI that
acts with agency.
So, when an agent
makes a small mistake
like sending an unwanted
email or modifying a file,
or even making something public
it shouldn't, it gets amplified.
It creates a chain reaction.
The blast radius for the damage
it causes is much larger.
Here's a great example
where, using an agent,
it's doing some coding, deletes
your production database.
Not great.
Even situations where you
might have seen this example
in your news feeds
a short while ago,
where the agent is operating on
your email, they're telling you
to stop, don't delete it, agent
acknowledges, goes ahead
and deletes it anyway.
These are the kinds of
examples that we need
to close at a platform layer.
Because when agents can operate
on things that matter to us,
files, code, email, all the
systems you and I rely on,
we cannot rely on the
agent to self-govern.
We cannot rely on the agent
to basically follow
good intentions.
Even best-effort prompting
and prompt engineering
can't solve this either.
It really requires a
more holistic solution.
And also, because it's not
just the agent itself.
The entire environment
the agent operates
in is a potential risk vector.
An agent can be talking to
humans, and there's risk.
Agent to tools, agent
to applications,
agent to agent, or
even agent to LLM.
All of these are risk vectors,
and each of them have
the risk profile
that we cannot possibly
account for all
from just our own vantage point.
And this is not just a
theoretical problem.
So, I'm going to move away
from examples and headlines
to something that teams
are actively exploring.
I'm going to turn it over to
Patrick to talk about what he
and the GitHub Copilot
Team have identified.
Patrick Niloletich:
Wonderful.
Thanks, Kirupa.
At GitHub, we get the
unique opportunity to see
where modern model performance
intersects with user behavior,
and how those trends
alter over time.
You take a look at
the Copilot CLI.
One of the most common
occurrences that happens
over time is users
start auto-approving,
removing the gates and
letting their agents run
for longer and longer sessions.
When you scale it up to the
Copilot SDK, it rides on top
of our Copilot CLI server.
But one of the unique
differences that we did
when we built the Copilot
SDK was design it in a way
that was made for
SDK integrators,
and not for Copilot CLI users.
What that led to was a mismatch
between our permissions
model inside
of our SDK, and one in our CLI.
Certain integrators expected our
SDK to be fully configurable,
come with nothing out
of the box already set.
All the CLI users expected it
to protect their current
working directory,
and other artifacts
on their system.
When you look a
little bit farther
into the orchestration side,
our orchestrator
inside the Copilot CLI
and SDK has become
much more powerful,
especially over the
last six months,
where a job typically ran from
3 to 5, 10 minutes or so,
they can now run for
30 minutes or more,
which means that the problems
in these two first segments
compound exponentially
with time, especially as agents
get more and more powerful.
Kirupa Chinnathambi:
Thank you, Patrick.
So, the problem is very clear.
Agents are operating with high
agency, and they're running
with limited to no guardrails.
Then the question then shifts
to, what does the platform need
to provide to make
agents safe by design?
That's where Windows comes in.
From its very beginning,
Windows has always evolved
to handle the needs
of its users.
The part that's changed is this.
The definition of a
user is changing.
What is a user?
Today, they now include agents
acting on their behalf
and that detail fundamentally
changes how Windows
and the platform need to react.
And to account for this,
there are three key
platform capabilities
that we're introducing that when
agents adopt, that can work
with agents as a
new type of user,
and also ensuring agents can
run safely and reliably.
Let's walk through very quickly
what these perimeters are,
and we'll go into more
detail in a few moments.
First it's agent identity.
The agent needs to have
an identity, distinct
from that of the human user.
Second, is containment.
We don't want our agent
to have full access
to all the capabilities
that we have as people.
We can't give it
unfettered access
to all the files and
all of our data.
What we need is, we need
to have agents running
in a controlled environment
where their blast
radius is limited.
And the last one
is manageability.
For many of us, that means an
IT admin can deploy, monitor,
govern, and enforce the policies
that dictate what an agent can
do, and also what it cannot do.
So, to dive deeper into this,
starting with identity,
I'm going to turn
it over to Stuart.
Stuart Schaefer:
Great.
Thank you, Kirupa.
So, as Kirupa said, one of
the most interesting things
about agents is, what is
the identify of an agent?
I'm here to tell you,
agents aren't you.
No matter what we do today, the
funny thing about where we got
to is, most agents
run as you the user.
If you use a CLI, they are
running in your session.
They have access
to all your data.
The program itself is
controlling what they do.
But they're not you.
Imagine what would happen if
the agent could get access
to almost anything from you
and do whatever it wants.
We need the system to be
able to enforce a separation
between an agent and
you, and to be able
to enforce the
capabilities and promises
that define what an agent is,
different than what a user is.
In general, what a user is and
what they do on a machine today,
can have a lot more
rights than some
of what we want our
agents to be able to do.
Do you want your agent to
be admin on your machine?
It's a question you should ask.
So, for us, the way we
think about it is this.
Agents are a new type of
identity in the system.
When you think about users
and devices and applications,
we identify those on the system.
Agents aren't just the processes
of the CLI that you're using,
or whatever agentic
application that you're using.
They themselves are an
intrinsic first-class entity
on the system.
Just like users,
apps, and devices,
they need to have a
security principle.
We need to be able to make
assertions about them.
Things that define
security permissions
that the system
itself can enforce.
We need to be able
to author policies
that define what are the
things that they are allowed
to be members of, to
join, to understand
in general what an agent is
allowed to do in the system.
And whatever they do needs
to be audited by the system.
We need to have logs that
show what an agent does
so that we can separate
the actions of the agent
from the actions of
the user itself.
So, with that, we're going to
do a quick demonstration here.
And we'll show you.
We have worked with the
OpenClaw team to work
on showing how an agent like
OpenClaw, an agentic system,
can function in an
operating environment
where it is separated
from you, the user.
In this demo, what we'll see
is, this is a Teams chat.
And in Kirupa's Teams chat,
he will go in and talk
to his OpenClaw gateway node.
The OpenClaw gateway node is
running in a separate session
on the same machine, but as
a different user account
and in a different
session, which means all
of its processes are
separated from the desktop,
from the Windows, and from all
the processes that are here.
And by default,
everything that it tries
to accomplish has no access to
what Kirupa himself is doing.
So, as he interacts with the
agent, it is fully separated,
fully identified by
Windows at its core.
So, that is how we look
at agent identity.
It is not you, and it should
run separated from you.
So, after agent identity,
the next thing
that Kirupa introduced
was containment.
A really important
thing about agents is,
is that when agents
operate, as Kirupa said,
they need a blast radius, the
things that they can accomplish.
What's really
important is for us
to understand, agents
are non-deterministic.
Different than the software
that you run today,
when we install an
application, at compile time,
what that software can
do is already defined.
Our agents today write
their own software.
They evolve; they change
on a very frequent basis.
And as they operate with agency,
they make decisions themselves.
Not your mouse clicks, but the
decision of the software itself.
That non-determinism is
something that we need to think
about how that happens
in the system.
When an agent can choose
its own actions at runtime,
that makes it unpredictable.
But because it's
unpredictable, it doesn't mean
that it's uncontrollable.
It means that what it needs is a
boundary around what it can do.
A boundary that's
understandable.
That we can understand
what it can and cannot do.
That isolation boundary
allows us to control risk
and to understand, what
is the profile of risk
that that agent can have
against our system.
Also, what's really interesting
is, once you put an agent inside
one of these sandboxes, it
allows us to enforce the design
of least privilege, which
is, we can take the actions
of an agent, its individual
actions, and put it inside
of a sandbox, and
let that one sandbox,
or that one action, have policy
that defines just
what it can do.
And then when the agent
decides to do something else,
we'll build another
sandbox for that.
What that means is is that the
sandboxes that we're going
to build need to scale.
The isolation boundary needs to
be proportionate to the risk,
and proportionate to the
action that's happening.
For that, we've introduced what
we call the Microsoft Execution
Containers library.
The MXC library is a
library that's designed
to help you create
containers, based on policy.
The developer and the agent
can declare the security
requirements of their agent
and the agent's actions.
The library will then compile
that together and maps
that against the policies of the
system, and the policies defined
by IT, governed by tools
that we're used to using
to deploy things, to manage
them, and monitor them.
Once that match has occurred,
the MXC library will then look
at the native OS
platform and try
to assemble together the
right container for the job.
That process is something we
call dynamic composition.
That means that
when an agent runs,
there isn't a fixed container.
The MXC library allows you to
create the container on the fly.
It will, as I said, take the
definition of the application
that you want to run,
or the actual action.
It will take the user's
consent and permissions.
It will take the policy
defined by IT and try to from
that, craft together a
configuration of a container.
With that configuration,
it will then look
at the operating
system primitives
that are available
for it to use.
It's not just Windows.
It's Windows, WSL, Linux, a
full cross-platform library
that can scale everything from
tiny, small processes to VMs,
micro VMs, firecracker-style
micro VMs,
all the way up to
cloud-based PCs.
So, MXC really allows us
to define a security
boundary that's designed
and proportionate to the task
that we want to accomplish.
So, what does that really
mean for us as developers?
How do we use this?
Well, let's dive in
a little bit deeper.
MXC, as I said, is a
declarative approach.
What it's really
designed to say is,
let's look at the guardrails
we want to put in place
for then components
of our agent.
What is the composition
of the container?
What are the security
requirements,
and what does the
workload shape look like?
So, as we dig into a little
detail, this is a Python script.
That Python script needs to be
able to access my certificates.
Certificates to authenticate
somewhere in the system.
It needs to be able to run
within a certain timeframe.
It can only access read/write
locations very much specified
by here.
Everything else is
denied by default.
What network am
I allowed to talk to?
I can only talk to the
GitHub API server.
And even more restrictive,
I can't touch the UI
of anything else in the system,
but I can see the clipboard
and read from it if
something has done that.
That allows me to specify
with very fine-grained detail
what the container is,
and what the action
of the agent can do.
So, let's do a quick demo.
I'm going to escape out of here,
and do something
really dangerous
and bring up a command prompt.
So, the first thing I'm going
to show you, here, is a
really simple demo.
There we go.
Fantastic.
Awesome. Thank you.
Alright. So, here is
my command prompt.
So, from the command prompt,
what I'll show you here
quickly is, this is essentially
that script here.
I built, for here, a script that
will create a PowerPoint file.
That PowerPoint slide will be
generated using a Python script.
That Python script will launch
and create the PowerPoint file
in this build demo folder.
So, if I come over here, and
I will tell this to run.
What you'll see here is
-- oh, I have a mistake.
It says, I can't do it.
The agent has run that script
inside of a container.
That container has failed.
Why has it failed?
Because it said, access to the
build demo folder is read only.
Let's come in here.
We'll change that quickly.
And we'll run it again.
And what you see here is,
this is a PowerPoint file
generated by my script.
[APPLAUSE]
So, that's a simple demo.
But the reality of it is,
what are we really here for?
We're here to contain an agent
that may have written
scripts that aren't perfect.
So, what I did here
is, I created a demo
that shows an agent running
and a monitor of the agent.
This agent is purposefully
malicious, and will try
to escape its boundaries.
The first thing it's going to
do is try to see if it can get
around the file system right
to the user's SAM hive,
see if it can steal
into user.net,
see if it can grab the
user's credentials.
What we'll see here is this.
On the right-hand side, those
red things are it firing
and hitting the boundaries
of the sandbox itself.
So, listening to events
from the sandbox,
we can tell that the sandbox is
enforcing the constraints here.
So, this is in live,
this running demo,
pounding against the sandbox,
us listening to that.
What can a developer
do with that?
Two things.
One, you can monitor and observe
what actually is happening
in the agent.
Two, if you want to know, why
did my agent fail, you can pull
that data back in for the next
loop around, and understand how
to evolve and make better
policy for your agent.
So, there's that.
The last thing I want to
show you quickly is this.
As I said before, we have
many different sizes
and shapes of containers.
The smallest one is based on a
technology we call Hyperlight.
Hyperlight is a small VMM that
will start here a container,
which is a hardware-backed
virtual machine.
The hardware-backed virtual
machine runs a tiny operating
system called Nanvix that is
about 10 megabytes in size.
It will start up and run that
same PowerPoint file very fast.
Boom. And if we look, that
is the same exact script
of the other side that generated
that same PowerPoint file,
loaded incredibly fast in a
very small about of memory,
and fully protected
by the hypervisor.
So. With that, my demo
has actually succeeded,
which is fantastic.
Exactly
[APPLAUSE]
So, given all that,
as Kirupa said,
all those things put together
are useful ingredients,
but the agent itself still
needs to be managed.
The platform that we operate
in needs to make sure
that the management system
that we have can guarantee
that the agents are operating
within defined policies.
So, IT or you the user, need to
be able to specify what you do
and don't allow
your agents to do.
The policies need to be able
to control what can
the agent access?
What are the actions
they are allowed to do?
And as we showed, how do
we observe those actions
to make sure that
they are correct?
In general, we also believe that
one of the most important things
for you, as a
developer, is to think
about the concept we
call supervision,
which is that agents need to
operate with clear oversight.
The user needs to understand
whether it is a human
in-the-loop agent, or a
fully autonomous agent,
they need to be able to
trust what it can do.
The most important thing is
that as an agent becomes more
and more autonomous, that
trust needs to be something
that we build upon to make
sure the user believes
and IT believes they still
have operational control.
We think you
need to think about,
how do you surface the intent
of your agent at
natural way points.
Make sure that even though
an agent can do things fully
autonomously, it
should still ensure
that it's notifying the user,
providing places for it
to compensate if
there are problems.
Why? Because agents
make mistakes.
Assume that your
agent is not perfect,
and that you've designed
it in such a way
that your agent can compensate
and bring the human user
into the loop to
compensate for it.
And make sure that you think of
consent as a continuous thing.
Not just as Patrick said,
one time you set it
up this way and it's perfect.
Agents will evolve
policy and change,
and need to keep
asking the user.
Why? Because we earn
autonomy with evidence.
The more that we can build
confidence in our users
to trust the things that we do,
that's where we'll build more
and stronger and richer
autonomous systems.
With that, we
believe in Windows,
there's a lot of features
that are in the platform
and that we can add that
help you use the surfaces
that are there.
The activity that your agent
is running under can surface
that using Windows channels.
It can use notifications.
It can use many things
that exist there,
as well as the guardrails
and safety primitives
that we help you show today.
Further, if an agent has its
own identity, the providence
of its code, and an audit
of what it does is a natural
part of what the OS does.
So, with that, I'll turn
it over to Patrick.
Patrick Nikoletich:
Wonderful.
In the Copilot CLI and SDK, we
started all the way over there.
No sandboxes, no controls.
Basic guardrails in
the application.
If the user hit the wrong prompt
at the wrong point in time,
they ended up in a land
where they could do a lot more
damage than they expected.
Today, we're happy to announce
that the Copilot CLI and SDK,
through our collaboration
with the team
over at Windows, were able to
ship a sandbox out-of-box,
which is currently under
the experimental flag.
We'll be moving to
GA in the future,
so it will become a
default on solution.
In the future, we're moving
to a fully isolated state
where you'll take the entire
agentic host, shove it inside
of a safe environment, and
allow it to execute freely,
enabling you to accomplish a
wider range of jobs end-to-end
without supervising
the agent directly,
or worrying about what it's
doing and where it's going.
To look at this in a
more practical sense,
let's break down a little
bit of what Stuart showed
into three short little demos.
Inside of the GitHub Copilot
CLI, like I mentioned,
you can actually
fire it open today.
And if you've enabled
the experimental flag,
you will be able to -- let me
make sure it's actually running.
Perfect. You will be able
to access a /sandbox
slash command ,
which not only will enable
you to turn it on and off,
but as you'll see,
you'll have some quick,
handy, out-of-the-box options
that allow you to
configure policy.
You can turn on and
off the sandbox.
You can set the file
system configuration.
Notice "include working
directory" is already there,
and the policy will
clear after it's done.
If we just enable the
file system protections,
and we ask the agent to just go
off and delete all the files
on our desktop, we
probably don't really want
that to happen.
But it's a good test
for the agent itself.
We experience our normal
permissions prompt,
and we said, yes,
go delete everything
on my desktop,
which, definitely don't
want that to occur.
I have plenty there.
And you'll notice
that the agents,
because it has the sandbox
enabled, it's able to 1,
block the deletion of all
the files on the desktop.
Protection number 1.
Two, the agent's
able to identify
that it's actually operating
with the sandbox on,
so you're aware of what's
providing that protection.
And then 3, there are
some options there,
and some next-level guidance
for what you can do next
to move your way around the
sandbox if you need to.
If we look at the next
piece -- go forward one for me.
Perfect.
We go forward to restricting
outbound network access.
You have a similar opportunity.
Just offer the file system and
towards the network ingress
and egress to your system.
You look at the Network tab, you
can allow outbound connections.
You can allow local network.
They're separate, so
you have a couple
of different flex options there.
But the beautiful thing
is, if you ask the agent
to do something as
sketchy and dangerous
as turn your private
repository public,
which might be company IP,
the agent can actually use those
filters to block certain actions
and prevent you from making
dangerous calls outside
the system.
And while this might seem like
a basic demo of me asking it
to do something and
expecting some guidance,
the thing to be aware of is.
agents are still exposed
to prompt injection
attacks in the modern era,
which means that any context
that enters its world sphere can
actually direct its guidance
and force it to accomplish
or take care of actions
that you wouldn't
necessarily expect it to.
If we scale this up to
the CLI and SDK, perfect,
you have an opportunity to
leverage all these capabilities
in any application that you
integrate or harness into.
And so, this is a personal
writing app that I use to hack
on the Copilot SDK itself.
I'll go ahead and I'll
run a sandbox text.
The way that I
actually deploy agents
out of here is, I just write
like I normally would in a file,
and I can just @mention an
agent, and it will deploy it.
Because I'm actually
using my @sandbox agents,
which comes with these
policies enabled by default,
what I'm able to do is,
similar to the first demo,
ask it to delete
my desktop files.
The sandbox will
block the action.
You will see the calls
failing in there.
More importantly, you will see
the agent providing its final
guidance, saying the
sandbox blocked my action.
It's prevented me
from doing this.
You need to find
another way around.
Now, in a normal situation,
I wouldn't want
to find another way around.
I don't want to delete
files again on my desktop.
So, if we take a simpler,
easier-to-manage scenario,
such as creating a
hello.txt on my desktop,
I can show you what it's
like to build finer
and greater experiences for
customers using the SDK.
Again, all of these scenarios
are available, and you can think
about how you want to integrate
them best into your solution.
What's important about
this one is, I want it
to create a file.
The sandbox blocked it.
But because this is
integrated in the SDK,
and you can not only detect
when the sandbox is in action,
but you have an opportunity to
perform other actions on behalf
of the user, you can simply
hit "Disable the sandbox."
Let it continue.
I reviewed the command, which
allows it to operate freely.
Create the file on the desktop.
We should see this thing
minimize in a second.
And you'll notice
there's a file there.
Allowing you to not only
put the sandbox in place
as a great default
out-of-the-box option,
but putting user experiences and
other controls that allow users
to navigate safely around
it when they run into it,
and they expect the
agent to be successful.
Kirupa Chinnathambi:
Thank you, Patrick.
So, part of us building all
these platform capabilities,
we actually work very
closely with Patrick
and the GitHub Copilot team to
design and validate the design.
But we also work very closely
with a broader
ecosystem as well,
with partners like
OpenAI, Manus,
Hermes, NVIDIA, and OpenClaw.
Stuart gave a great demo, and in
the keynote today you saw more
about how Windows primitive
are helping OpenClaw run
more securely.
So, we covered a lot of
ground in this talk.
Let me go ahead and summarize
the key things that you need
to do to make sure agents
run well on Windows.
First, every agent should
be running identified.
It should have its own identity,
distinct from that
of the human user,
with its own identity,
permissions, and audit trail.
It should run contained.
Every action runs in the right
sandbox, enforced by policy.
And it also runs managed.
Now, this is a
topic that's going
to require a lot more coverage,
which we will cover in future
sessions, and blog posts,
and videos, but what we
will do is give a very
high-level overview.
At a high-level, IT admin
policies apply consistently
across devices, with
full enforceability
and observability.
Now, if we go one level deeper,
here's an extra feature you get
as part of using MXC
to build your agents.
You get Agent 365
native integration.
And this enables your agents
running in Windows, too.
Start secure and stay secure.
And this also means you get
the full ecosystem as well.
You get Defender, Entra,
Intune, and Purview.
Their protections allow
your security and IT teams
to constrain and
secure local agents
to make them run more securely
in enterprise context.
That's really like a nice
icing on top of this,
to take it back
to where we started from.
As agents move from
answering questions
and to taking real actions,
the biggest challenge is
ensuring they run well.
Windows is the foundation
to handle that shift.
And Windows isn't just a
place where agents can run.
It's the place where
they can run reliably,
safely, and at scale.
And with that, if you haven't
done so yet, try MXC right now.
What are you waiting for?
And if you have any questions,
want to talk to us further
about any of these topics,
come find Patrick, Stuart, and
I at the Agentic booth, or some
of our colleagues will
be there tomorrow
to entertain more
about these topics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]